naval warfare in the future could be
waged by robotic eels and scientists at
the University of Colorado have
discovered an invisible doughnut-shaped
shield roughly 7,200 miles above Earth
comprised of high-energy electrons and
protons that protect us from killer
electrons Vsauce Kevin here this is mine
every password you use can be replaced
by your eyeball Myra's converts the
one-of-a-kind characteristics of your
iris into an encrypted code unique to
you the device stores no data not even
an image of your eye so you won't have
to worry about someone stealing your
password and it features a significantly
lower false ID acceptance rate compared
to voice recognition fingerprints or
facial recognition at one in one and a
half million
so no more usernames no more passwords
only eyeball this Lego body is
controlled by an implanted worm brain
the open worm project has mapped the
connections between the worms 302
neurons and simulates them in software
the Lego robot mimics the behavior of an
actual worm ceasing to move when it's no
sensor bumps into a wall avoiding being
touched and moving forward when its food
sensor is stimulated this can someday
lead to technology that simulates a
human brain which would revolutionize
computers and artificial intelligence an
800-page book from 1692 contains a
hand-painted archive of every color
created by someone known simply as a
booger it was intended to be an
educational guide on how to mix and
identify colors find the link below to
view the entire book in high-res
ultrasound creates 3d objects that can
be seen and felt in mid-air developed at
the University of Bristol
it focuses complex patterns of
ultrasound and these shapes can be felt
and manipulated in real time potential
for this includes allowing surgeons to
explore a CT scan by feeling a disease
such as a tumor IVA is the world's first
smart shower device designed to save
water can be attached to any existing
shower head and uses motion sensors to
adjust how much water flows depending
upon how close you are they claim it
saves up to 50% of water usage and it
can also monitor water temperature so
the shower starts exactly as warm as you
like it electric eels discharge
electricity similarly to a Taser
they stun their prey with high voltage
10 to 15 mil
impulses and can use electricity to
force hiding animals to give away their
locations they overwhelm the nerves that
control the muscles causing them to
involuntarily contract and basically
biological Tasers full facial
transplants are possible thanks to 3d
printing a 3d model of a patient's head
is constructed using cat scans and then
printing which tells surgeons where the
vessels are to match the tissues
perfectly which is integral in the
healing process of transplanting a new
face and nine of these procedures have
occurred in the US since 2011
researchers in South Korea have
developed an artificial skin designed to
mimic real human skin the stretchable
polymer features networks of sensors
made of gold in silicon that senses
touch pressure and moisture it could
give artificial limbs feeling and even
has a layer of actuators that warm it up
to the same temperature as human skin
Stanford University researchers have
created a climbing system to scale walls
like a gecko the sticky pads were
inspired by gecko toes which are
extremely sticky due to being covered
with thin long spatula shaped structures
that increase surface area and amplify
electrical attractions between the toes
and a surface this adhesive could be
used to make grippers for manipulating
huge objects without the need for
suction power or chemical glues finally
Felix 3 is a human powered bicycle
capable of reaching a record 83 miles
per hour and the team at Delft
University is working on breaking their
own record with Felix 4 I'm holding a
standard chain in my hand a special
chain developed by DSM the rollers are
made out of a Stan old plastic to lower
the friction and steel to steel friction
is higher than the steel to plastic
friction so we have one like 1% in
efficiency this will contribute
definitely to getting higher speeds I'm
gonna leave you with a virtual reality
game inspired by lucid dreaming and as
always thanks for watching